you are an essential part of a perfect
social body everybody in their place
everybody happy now the book brave new
world was written in the 1930s and yet
it's still describing something that we
relate to to this utopian world but it's
really about well what kind of dystopia
does that create inside there's two
worlds the savage lands in New London
the Savage Land people are truly free
but they have nothing new London
everybody feels like they're getting
everything they want when in fact
they're being told what they want the
new one and everybody's put into a class
system that's really strict and
conditioned to make them feel that that
class is exactly where they should be
everyone has a place everyone has a
function everybody happy now in the new
world monogamy doesn't exist love
doesn't exist that will create jealousy
that will create possessiveness that
will create secrecy people self-regulate
they take a pill called soma and it'll
toggle whatever you're deficient in and
for you up so no one ever feels any sort
of negative sensations no one questions
the way the world is run it just is and
everyone's perfectly happy with that
when you meet John he's stuck in the
savage lands where there's none of the
luxury none of the ways that new
Londoners have of keeping themselves in
good moods
he's company how you people feel welcome
with the real world he's the person who
hasn't been taking these drugs he hasn't
had that conditioning he hasn't been put
in this clear societal role so when he
actually gets taken to this crazy New
London world I think
things that John does is start poking
holes a little bit maybe there's
something missing when pain is gone
we're gonna die here I might as well
have a drink this has an opportunity to
take people on a journey and really
challenge some of their existing beliefs
it's really not about the future it's
really about our brave new world is
provocative its energetic and it's fast
and it's gonna be absolutely amazing the
scope of this show is so enormous we
have world-class filmmakers I mean it's
unreal every time I get to a certain I
think you didn't leave to do all of this
and I'm so glad you did this was an
opportunity to revisit such a great book
the show in many ways it mirrors the
book but it reflects where we are
culturally today the way that the world
is painted in the script was something
that really knocked my socks off all the
aesthetics of the show and the design of
it are just magnificent
but also interesting as far as the
storytelling this was supposed to be a
city designed by an artificial
intelligence so we actually did quite
detailed layouts of the buildings and
then that would influence Italy the way
that they looked we were inside one the
other day that was like being on the
inside of a whale like seeing the ribs
it was enormous scope very authentic
very real I've never experienced a
costume department like on this job the
Wardrobe is incredible its iridescent
materials put together in the most
beautiful way it feels 3d
hmm No one of the biggest things you get
with brave new world is the level of
visual effect the whole thing is just
kind of visually incredible and the
whole look of the show is going to be is
different I think the show will feel
somehow grand and also intimate at the
same time the Casas bananas I've been so
lucky to work with such amazing talents
am I ready I loved the story I couldn't
picture it it was almost too big that's
something that really drew me to it and
I'm so excited to see how it comes
together you just need to embrace this
place and let it be wonderful
all of us Huxley imagined a world where
people would be so pharmacologically
numb so sexually stimulated so
distracted by the superficial and
ephemeral moments of life and I think
parts of our culture have drifted
towards his prediction the way that
David and all the other writers have
translated Huxley's ideas into this
story felt really profound and really
pertinent and the question that it kind
of poses is what it really means to be
happy
quite frankly my friend if you're not
happy you're nothing at all the story in
itself is I think it really timely it
gives us a view of a society that is not
completely different from our own our
society today you like to put a bandaid
on things without actually looking at
the root of the problem Simon is the
pill that keeps you on this beautiful
balance the idea of an order and a pill
to make you happy and taking away some
of our choices you're going to take the
recommended actions and you are going to
feel better I think of something called
painting a lot of people today Huxley
was seeing into the future this world
where we could just entertain ourselves
we can get so good at making any kind of
discomfort or pain go away you know
you've got your future where you
wouldn't have to ban a book because no
one would care to read one and why would
she need to there's just so much else to
do
and if Huxley was writing about that in
1932 and we have continued to go closer
toward that you really start questioning
things people open no idea how good you
have it sometimes I think I want to be
unhappy but when I think about braving
the world it's kind of captures this
idea of an unknown and a certain amount
of hope that we're gonna get it figured
out the inability to conform is always
interesting to see humanity burst
through that's what makes the show so
exciting
you